Welcome to Godolken University
it's a safe space for you to thrive
I'm ready
where did you find that kind of courage
I'm superhuman right we're made of steel
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie they dropped a
trailer for The Boys gen V so I'll explain what's
going on what the series is all about all the
Marvel the DC references because there are a
lot of very obvious Comics references in this from
both big Brands if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get the episodes I will
do videos for the series when it premieres next
year but the boys gen V is meant to be a spin-off
of the main series that's why you see so many of
the main series characters during this like see
a bunch of homelander all the people on the show
think of him as a God because that's the way that
Vaught portrays him there's a train wearing the
vot merch inside the sevens Tower in their main
meeting room there there's Ashley they even have
the director of the vot dawn of the seven which
is kind of a Justice League but also an Avengers
Endgame parody movie The funny thing about that
too is that they didn't know that Charlize Theron
was going to be in Doctor Strange Multiverse
of Madness as Cleo when they did that they did
that before she did Doctor Strange Multiverse
of Madness but it only helps the metaphor like
the whole idea that she's playing this superhero
character is just that inside the universe of the
vot she's playing the actress Charlize Theron like
she actually exists canon in the universe of the
boys now but her powers in the Marvel Universe
also manifest as purple just like stormfront's
powers the boy's gen V title stands for Generation
Vaught as in compound B the series is mostly set
at this school godokin University it's meant
to be a parody of X-Men with the school for
gifted youngsters like the X-Mansion in The Hunger
Games where the candidates the classmates slowly
wind up killing each other in a contest where the
winner gets to join the seven like secretly though
the school is just meant to be a meat grinder
testing ground for Vaught used to see if any of
the rejects that they discarded earlier have any
potential as future assets or if any of the kids
that they thought weren't a big deal at the time
when they initially got compound B whose Powers
took longer to manifest or they didn't fully
understand their powers when they got them might
actually wind up being legit like Voght is holding
a battle royale between all the kids with reject
compound V powers in the person who graduates and
joins the seven is the one left standing that's
why it seems like throughout the trailer the
tragedies get worse and worse and worse like it
seems like quintessential college experience but
also along the way things get worse and worse and
worse more and more them keep dying this is all
the statues of homelander because he is like their
God I'm sure that'll go well I'll explain the boys
season 4 as well because they're in the middle of
shooting that too there'll be a lot of crossover
between this and the boys season four inside the
hallway you see a train's vending machine for his
turbo Rush drink because the university is funded
by vot like most everything else like I said it's
a secret testing ground for vot that they're just
pretending is like a regular College all the
warning signs in the doors have black noir on
them because black noir was literally watching
them on the DL and would kill any of the kids
if they went off the rails or lost control their
powers in a public way doing anything that would
negatively affect Vaude although in present
day homelanders killed black noir sovat has
this police force that comes to kill anyone who
gets out of line with a bunch of super deterrents
but even though it seems like black noir is dead
the showrunner teased that that wasn't the end of
the black noir character he could come back the
same way that Stormfront came back like a broken
husk because they're so powerful they can survive
almost anything even though though it seems like
he was killed he could survive that or he could
come back as a hallucination in homelander's mind
because he's going crazier and crazier as the
series gets on which I think is more interesting
because he thought black noir is this great friend
of his so of course he feel remorseful about
having killed him he even seemed like he regretted
it while he was doing it there's a whole bunch of
new characters obviously they introduce like the
actual kids that have powers who will be attending
this school battling it out for a place on the
seven one of the new main ones is called Marie
M she was featured during the boy season 3 at Red
River Institute you might remember that was vod's
special school for the compound B children that
they felt like were failures or that the parents
couldn't handle because their powers were too
great or too out of control you actually see her
go back to that school during the trailer with
the knife in her hand it says that fog created
the 1960s that could be a lie because I think the
idea is that Stan Edgar created it and was looking
to mine any potential assets from it that's how
Huey found out about Victoria Newman because he
was snooping into her backstory and found out
that she'd been dumped there as a child because
she'd accidentally killed her parents parents so
they treated it kind of like an orphanage like
vought's orphanage for superhero kids and at some
point during her childhood Stan Edgar realized her
potential and raised her like his own daughter
training her to be just as much of a player
as devious as he was which is why he seemed so
bemused when she stabbed him in the back betrayed
him to homelander that's why it seemed like he was
proud that she did that even though it affected
him negatively like ah the student has become the
master it wasn't that she hated Stan Edgar it was
that she wanted to protect her daughter who is
now her compound V daughter because it was all
about homelander bringing them the compound V the
permanent compound B and because she used that to
become Senator Robert singer's running mate is
Vice President I've already talked about all
the supernatural Easter eggs because obviously the
Robert Singer character is played by an actor from
Supernatural they had Jensen Ackles as soldier boy
during season three and they're gonna have Jeffrey
Dean Morgan during season four I don't know who
he's supposed to play but Jeffrey Dean Morgan will
be a character during season four she and Robert
Singer will probably win the presidency during
season four though don't know what Ashley is doing
during this trailer but I love that she seems
horrified by what she's saying because that's kind
of her vibe there were a couple references during
season three that Ashley secretly wanted to be
a good person like she did a couple good things
but she did ultimately want to keep her position
inside but so she was continuing to uphold status
quo probably one of the other biggest WTF like
head-jerking moments during the trailer is the
puppets there are a couple different types of
scenes with puppets that I think are meant to
be completely different things like you have Jason
Ritter playing what looks like a Mr Rogers parody
character with a puppet version of the deep on
what seems like a vot-funded version of Sesame
Street in this universe I love that the puppet
has a five o'clock shadow in the gills the Avenue
v stands for Avenue vought it's both an Avenue Q
reference and a Sesame Street reference I think
the idea with this particular cartoon is that
it's one of vought's children's programs that
the little kids are meant to watch and it's their
way of selling products indoctrinating little kids
like getting all the little kids of the world to
worship the seven and also really just get them
hooked on buying vot merch remember at least up to
the events of season 2 Stan Edgar's long-term plan
was really just to use vought as this money making
machine for merchandising purposes like that was
the whole reason that they use compound B create
superheroes so that we could use them to profit
from the big change though is that during season
two Stan Edgar said we're going to become more of
a core pharmaceutical company because we can earn
way more money selling this temporary compound V
to the military than we can through merchandising
so like up to this point in history they're meant
to be like the most evil version of Disney you
could possibly imagine like imagine all the
Marvel movies if Marvel actually created those
superheroes but only did it so that they could
create all the Disney merchandise all the Disney
movies that they make then suddenly Disney pivoted
and said no we're not going to do that anymore
we're going to become more like Pfizer but then
you have this completely other scene where there's
a puppet killing someone in a really graphic way
it seems like it's totally different type of
scene like someone's hallucinating it and it's
not from the Avenue V TV show like they wouldn't
be putting this into children's television show
so it's probably somebody hallucinating it you
might recognize Patrick Schwarzenegger I don't
know what his powers are going to be he said
that he told his father Arnold Schwarzenegger
about what was going on with the show because
Arnold Schwarzenegger did all those 80s 90s
even present-day action movies and he said the
Arnold just could not believe it like what is
going on with this show like he tried to explain
the boys to Arnold Schwarzenegger even Arnold
Schwarzenegger couldn't believe it the very dark
funny moment here with the vought police force
dragging the person in sweats is them taking
whoever this is with powers back to their dorm
room slash prison cell because that's kind of
the whole vibe of this University is that it's
a testing ground these are meant to be holding
cells for the people with superpowers they're
just making it seem like it's a university and
this is a fun quintessential college experience
when really this is just a really complex
experiment that vought scientists are running
you'd probably recognize chance perdomo he's been
in a bunch of stuff recently there are a couple
of familiar actors throughout this and they only
say the release date is during 2023 in the trailer
but given the timing for when they released
first trailers like this usually that means
the next six months so I'm assuming this is going
going to release episodes in the summer next year
sometime The Boys season 4 will either release
at the end of next year if they can finish it in
time or early 2024. the whole thing with the boys
season 4 is that now homelander has seen that he
can literally do anything and his fans will love
him no matter what no matter how terrible he is
they will still love him and that was what he was
worried about before but now the chains are off
so to speak like oh I can actually do anything if
he didn't pick up on it during season three it is
meant to be a total culture War metaphor Ryan's
brain kind of broke a little bit because of what
he went through he wanted some kind of normalcy
like he wanted a family so badly that he did these
mental gymnastics that a lot of children living
in abusive households do where they believe that
that kind of behavior is normal around them he
saw homelander being terrible and then getting
all this love from everyone so his brain did
the mental gymnastics to say oh no that's normal
that's the way you're supposed to act you don't
have to hide who you are you don't have to hide
your powers and season 4 is really like the battle
for Ryan's soul and the problem now is the butcher
who's still trying to do right by him is just as
bad as homelander in reality and everybody hates
him he just terrible in the opposite direction
like there are two sides of the same coin both
of them are terrible people headed for mutually
assured destruction but I think the idea is that
butcher will eventually try to do something that
will really save Ryan and he'll be the person to
ultimately kill homelander like butcher even with
the temporary compound V jacking him up won't be
enough to kill homelander because he's meant to be
so powerful if it wasn't clear there's no kind of
powers work around for homelander he is meant
to be nigh unkillable Invincible in the boy's
universe that's how powerful he is so nobody is
meant to be able to go toe-to-toe with him in
a prolonged fight except except for maybe Ryan
that's why ultimately in whatever final season
the boys winds up doing I don't know how many
seasons it'll wind up running it'll be Ryan to
be the one to have to kill him but if you spotted
any other Easter eggs during the trailer that I
didn't talk about in the video or have any big
questions about the series just write them in
the comments below we'll get another trailer in
a couple more months there are a bunch of other
trailers this past weekend because of ccxp Brazil
Comic Con so I'll try to do videos for everything
be sure to enable alerts for my channel so
you don't miss any of that click here for my
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 trailer video and click
here for my brand new Ant-Man the Wasp Quantumania
Kang video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!